[Musique]
une
1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
salut tout le monde alors une fois n'est
pas coutume cette semaine je vais vous
montrer un jeu adapté d'un film un bon
feeling d'ailleurs au passage total
recall alors total recall mine de rien
ça fait déjà 20 ans pour certains le
seul souvenir du film ce sera ça pour
d'autres par contre ce sera ça et pour
ceux qui ne connaîtraient pas total
recall est un film de science-fiction
action avec arnold changer n'est guère
donc si vous ne connaissez pas le mieux
c'est encore d'aller le voir par vous
même quand même arnold schwarzenegger a
vraiment pas eu de bol sur ces
adaptations jeu puisque la plupart des
jeux adaptés de ses films sont
complètement pourri last action hero
predator terminator c'est tous des
besoins et total recall c'est exactement
pareil sans genre de plateforme bi nzé
mode cloud développées par interpellé
c'est bourré de problèmes de gameplay
avec une difficulté mais complètement
stupide sérieux mais dieu lui-même ne
pourrait pas finir ce jeu est c'est
parti pour des heures de souffrance
devrait demander si tu me rembourse à
chacun des tests a pour sauter et b pour
tirer ou frapper ok donc là je vais à 20
super très bien on commande directe en
fanfare je me suis fait choper dans une
ruelle la part pas je sais pas un pygmée
pakistanais rose fait on dirait que
ninja l'a vu comme ils sont aussi
d'ailleurs le mec il mesure 1 mètre de
moins que moi mais là une meilleure
allonge faut dire aussi que choisit dans
ce jeu il a les bras greffer au corps il
tape qu'avec des avant-bras en fait
ce super voilà même pas le temps de
réagir en sortant je me fait tirer
dessus dans tous les jeux en fait je
m'attend mais un sérum est sérieux mais
ça va être comme ça toutes les ruelles
ou quoi en fait dans le niveau on flippe
en passant devant chaque ruelle comme
une jeune pucelle perdu la nuit dans une
banlieue sombre
surtout que ces machins ne sert
absolument à rien ça casse le rythme et
si tu as le malheur de faire un pas en
arrière par réflexe en sortant pour
éviter la voiture de ça recommence
tu te fais choper dans la même rue elle
tend le même mec à 30 secondes d'écart
tu peux bien le chercher la barre
d'énergie mais ouais merde tard oui je
sais c'est complètement con faire ça
c'est comme si le fait de faire ça avec
la manette vous faisait sauter plus loin
sinon bah il ya d'autres trucs
intéressants on ce niveau houphouet g/j
bien une idée de ce que c'est très bon
il paraît qu'à des jeunes qui regardent
niveau 2 c'est là où ça commence à
devenir tendue quand on connaît pas il
faut tamas et la donzelle rapidement et
vous barrez et si vous êtes trop lent il
ya silvio berlusconi qui arrivent et qui
vous tue non mais sérieux franchement
c'est lui dont on dirait je trouve au
bout de quelques coups donc l axone
armes sauf que lorsque vous êtes à côté
d'un ennemi larmes tiers dans le vent
bonjour l'utilité du flingue
donc il faut tuer la nana tout en
restant du côté droit et ensuite se
jeter sur silvio pour finir le niveau
parce qu'évidemment il est un tiago
clegg il vous tient d'un coup un
évidemment sinon c'est pas drôle
je suis bloqué j'ai plus comme celui-ci
les foutus trop qu'on pourra en peine de
toute façon maintenant que j'y pense
quand même j'aurais dû me méfier dans
l'intro du jeu ils disent on t'a mais
promis des vacances sur mars tout ce que
tu as eu ce sont des migraines des
pertes de mémoire et des mecs qui essaye
de te buter j'avoue que si tu changes de
mots sa cote presque au jeu quoi
bon après il faut reconnaître que le je
suis assez bien l'histoire du film les
niveaux sont même entrecoupés de
dialogue
[Musique]
oui c'est un dialogue exactement oui
enfin j'avoue quand même que je me
souviens pas du passage du film où il
affronte des clochards jedi ni de celui
où il affronte le roi des clochards en
fait je viens il ya juste un moment dans
le film où il rentre dans un bâtiment
abandonné abandonné abandonnez vous
savez ce que ça veut dire mais c'est
vrai dans les jeux dérivés de films
c'est toujours la même chose en fait on
te prend une scène dans le film qui dure
cinq secondes et dans le jeu on en fait
un niveau entier et je veux dire mais à
réfléchir comme ça on pourrait très
bientôt sortir un bide des vols sur
amélie poulain qui du tout-monde à
montmartre on peut dire qu à but non
marrast blé non non non non là parce
qu'elle fait avant marche des cochons
au passage ce beau cela le super
clochard il est impossible à faire
normalement
le boss est immunisée au bal sauf sur sa
tête donc pour le tuer il faut sauter en
permanence et tirer pitt sur une fenêtre
de tir large de 2 pixels et tout ça en
évitant le chapeau donc la solution ici
c'est non seulement de trouver un bug
mais en plus de monter d'abord au
maximum sa barre d'énergie avance avant
du fait que les clochards et apparaît
sans arrêt à chaque changement d'écran
et que des fois il lâche une canette qui
vous redonne un tiers de minibar il ya
huit mini bar donc faut 24 canettes et
évidemment pour plus de fun ça ne tombe
que une fois sur trois
cette musique et recommencent à chaque
changement d'écran sérieux et les
oreilles pouvez vous revenir mais je
vous jure qu'elle le forez savez vous
imaginez mais c'est comme si un zelda la
musique se répéter à chaque changement
d'écran ce genre de détails qui te font
détester un jour
[Musique]
quand j'entends un faut que les gens
deviennent violents parce qu'ils ont
trop joué à gta mais moi je te jure que
ce jeune donc dix fois plus envie tu es
tout le monde que j'étais a donc pour
tuer le boss il faut se placer derrière
lui pour fac il se retourne mais pas
trop près pour pas prendre de coups et
avec du bol bout le tueur est peut-être
en fait pour résumer la meilleure
stratégie c'est vous mettez derrière lui
et mon pionner votre manette comme un
crétin vraiment c'est beau à voir
le
l'affrontement ultime de clodo et de
notices tu comment tu peux entendre
huisne est un bon film c'est impossible
et après devinez quoi
devinez ce qu'il faut faire maintenant
il faut reçu des clochards parce
qu'entre chaque niveau le jeu ne vous
redonne aucune barre de vie on dirait
que le moindre détail a été calculée
pour vous a merdé un maximum eh ouais
même les tentatives de faire des trucs
un peu originaux c'est au final des bons
gros et rond je veux dire le niveau sur
mars mais il faut le voir pour y croire
sérieux y'a pas moyen de tourner
normalement
la voiture ne tourne pas je ne sais pas
ce que c'est parce qu'elle fait glisse
comme comme une luge on dirait donc du
coup au final à chaque angle on se cogne
partout c'était trop demandé de rajouter
la possibilité de tourner la voiture
tout simplement géré merde c'est pas
sorcier quand même
regardez là c'est typique pourquoi est
ce que là ça ne passe pas pourquoi
est-ce que le je considère que je ne
suis pas aligné alors que je fais la
même chose ensuite de l'autre côté en
roulant sur le pur sang prouve les
verbes quand c'est bon j'en ai marre
j'en ai plein le cul je veux dire je
sais pas pourquoi je fais chier à jouer
à ce jeu alors que je pourrais faire des
trucs plus intéressant dans ma vie j'en
sais rien comme comme trier mes
chaussettes à l'ailé ça suffit merde
t'as ta gueule bon vous savez comme je
vous ai dit au début que les jeux de
schwarzy était vraiment pété c'est
vraiment pas pourrir d'heure mais je
vais vous en montre un dernier predator
sortir aux états unis jamais arrivé en
france c'est pour ça que je vais
utiliser un adaptateur qui va nous
permettre d'y jouer
alors s'il a jamais passé la frontière
c'est qu'il ya bien une raison c'est
qu'en fait ce jeu les deux gros doit
dresser dans le ciel à tous les fans du
film on contrôle donc choisi dans son
petit juste corps rose qui se promène
dans la jungle au milieu de scorpions
qui clignotait de guérilleros ce
dépressif puisque en fait pas besoin de
les tuer ils se suicident tous la
trentaine de niveaux de ce jeu est très
varié on passe notamment des jeux blancs
aux cavernes au jungle aux cavernes au
jeu blanc les parties de plateformes
sont de vrai plaisir surtout quand on
passe à travers sans raison mais
heureusement le level design est
rattrapé par la grande variété des
ennemis et la manière dont ce je
respecte le film on se souvient tous par
exemple des scènes ou choir et n'est
guère affrontent des méduses volantes
des paramécies des pizzas des bulles de
savon des gambas sauvages ou des oiseaux
qui chie du sang d'ailleurs c'est sympa
ya même d'autres personnages de jeux
vidéos qui sont venus boire un café
salut truc qui ressemble à bomberman
salue les fantômes de mario à et je
crois que si tu veux me predator qui
n'était pas un homme je ne suis pas sûr
en fait plus le jeu avance plus je pense
qu'en réalité tout ça n'est qu'un rêve
et que choisie et ivre mort dans un
caniveau en train de manger son vomi
bref le mieux à faire avec ce jeu c'est
encore de faire comme les guérilleros
c'est d'utiliser une commande spéciale
du jeu qui montre que même les
développeurs savait qu'il faisait de la
merde
appuyez sur start puis a ou b et hop
suicide
[Musique]
vraiment sérieusement il ya des jeux qui
mérite vraiment pas de vivre sérieux
[Musique]
la butte de montmartre non parce que
abus un mandat pour ta vie de combat